my name is Katrina spade and I grew up
in a medical family where it was fairly
normal to talk about death and dying at
the dinner table but I didn't go into
medicine like so many of my family
members instead I went to architecture
school to learn how to design and while
I was there I began to be curious about
what would happen to my physical body
after I died what would my nearest and
dearest do with me so if the existence
in the fact of your own mortality
doesn't get you down the state of our
current funerary practices will today
almost 50% of Americans choose
conventional burial conventional variola
begins with embalming where funerals
fast drain bodily fluid and replace it
with a mixture designed to preserve the
corpse and give it a lifelike glow then
as you know bodies are buried in a
casket in a concrete lined grave in a
cemetery all told in u.s. cemeteries we
bury enough metal to build a Golden Gate
Bridge enough wood to build 1800
single-family homes and enough
formaldehyde Laden embalming fluid to
fill eight Olympic sized swimming pools
in addition cemeteries all over the
world are reaching capacity turns out it
doesn't really make good business sense
to sell someone a piece of land for
eternity
whose idea was that in some places you
can't buy a plot no matter how much
money you have
as a result cremation rates have risen
fast in 1950 if you suggested your
grandmother be incinerated after she
died you'd probably be kicked from the
family deathbed but today almost half of
Americans choose cremation citing
simpler cheaper and more ecological as
reasons I used to think that cremation
was a sustainable form of disposition
but just think about it for a second
cremation destroys the potential we have
to give back to the earth after we've
died it uses an energy intensive process
to turn bodies into ash polluting the
air and contributing to climate change
all told cremations in the u.s. emit a
staggering 600 million pounds of carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere annually the
truly awful truth is that the very last
thing that most of us will do on this
earth is poison it it's like we've
created accepted and death denied our
way into a status quo that puts as much
distance between ourselves and nature as
is humanly possible our modern funerary
practices are designed to stave off the
natural processes that happen to a body
after death in other words they're meant
to prevent us from decomposing but the
truth is that nature is really really
good at death we've all seen it when
organic material dies in nature microbes
and bacteria break it down into
nutrient-rich soil completing the life
cycle in nature death creates life back
in architecture school I was thinking
about all this and I set out on a plan
to redesign death care could I create a
system that was beneficial to the earth
that used nature as a guy
rather than something to be feared
something that was gentle to the planet
that planet after all supports our
living bodies our whole lives and while
I was mulling this all over over the
drawing board the phone rang it was my
friend Kate she was like hey have you
heard about the farmers who are
composting whole cows and I was like hmm
[Music]
turns out that farmers and agricultural
institutions have been practicing
something called livestock mortality
composting for decades mortality
composting is where you take an animal
high in nitrogen and cover it with Co
composting materials that are high in
carbon it's an aerobic process so it
requires oxygen and it requires plenty
of moisture as well in the most basic
setup a cow is covered with a few feet
of wood chips which are high in carbon
and left outside for nature for breezes
to provide oxygen and rain to provide
moisture in about nine months all that
remains the nutrient-rich compost the
flesh has been decomposed entirely as
have the bones I know so I would
definitely call myself a decomposition
nerd but I am far far from a scientist
and one way you can tell this is true is
that I have often called the process of
composting magic
so basically all we humans need to do is
create the right environment for nature
to do its job it's like the opposite of
antibacterial soap instead of fighting
them we welcome microbes bacteria in
with open arms these tiny amazing
creatures break down molecules into
smaller molecules and atoms which are
then incorporated into new molecules in
other words that cow is transformed it's
no longer a cow it's been cycled back
into nature see magic you can probably
imagine the light bulb that went off in
my head after I received that phone call
I began designing a system based on the
principles of livestock mortality
composting that would take human beings
that transform them into soil fast
forward five years and the project has
grown in ways I truly never could have
imagined we've created a scalable
replicable nonprofit urban model based
on the science of livestock mortality
composting that turns human beings into
soil we've partnered and collaborated
with experts in soil science
decomposition alternative death care law
and architecture we've raised funds from
foundations and individuals in order to
design a prototype of the system and
we've heard from tens of thousands of
people all over the world who want this
option to be available okay in the next
few years it's our goal to build the
first full-scale human composting
facility right in the City of Seattle
[Applause]
imagine eight part public park part
funeral home part memorial to the people
we love a place where we can reconnect
with the cycles of nature and treat
bodies with gentleness and respect the
infrastructure is simple inside a
vertical core bodies and woodchips
undergo accelerated natural
decomposition or composting and are
transformed into soil when someone dies
their body is taken to a human
composting facility after wrapping the
deceased in a simple shroud friends and
family carry the body to the top of the
core which contains the natural
decomposition system during a laying in
ceremony they gently place the body into
the core and cover it with woodchips
this begins the gentle transformation
from human to soil over the next few
weeks the body decomposes naturally
microbes and bacteria break down carbons
and protein to create a new substance a
rich earthy soil this soil can then be
used to grow new life eventually you
could be a lemon tree yeah thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
who's thinking about lemon meringue pie
right now a lemon drop something
stronger so in addition to housing a
core these buildings will function to
support the grieving by providing space
for memorial services and end-of-life
planning the potential for repurposing
is huge old churches and industrial
warehouses can be converted into places
where we create soil and honor life we
want to bring back the aspect of ritual
that's been diluted over the past
hundred years as cremation rates have
risen and religious affiliation has
declined our Seattle facility will
function as a model for these places all
over the world we've heard from
communities in South Africa Australia
the UK Canada and Beyond we're creating
a design tool kit that will help others
design and build facilities
it will contain technical specifications
and regulatory best practices we want to
help individuals organizations and down
the road municipalities design and build
facilities in their own cities the idea
is that every one of these places should
look and feel completely different with
the same system inside they're really
meant to be designed for the
neighborhood in which they reside and
the community which they serve the other
idea is for supportive staff to be on
hand to help families with a care and
preparation of loved ones bodies
we're banishing practices that bewilder
and disempower and creating a system
that is beautiful and meaningful and
transparent we believe that access to
ecological death care is a human right
okay so you know the old saying if you
can compost a cow you can compost a
human
turns out it's true since 2014 we've
been running a pilot project in the
hills of North Carolina with the
forensic anthropology department at
Western Carolina University six donor
bodies have been covered in woodchips
oxygen provided by breezes microbes and
bacteria doing their jobs this pilot
program has allowed us to demonstrate
that it's possible to harness the
incredible power of natural
decomposition to turn human bodies into
soil and we're working with other
universities as well
soil scientists at Washington State
University the grad students anyway are
working to compost teas with amalgam
fillings so that we can understand what
happens to the mercury they're in next
up will be beginning experiments to
determine what happens to chemo drugs
and pharmaceuticals during a composting
process and whether additional
remediation will be needed by the way
composting creates a great deal of heat
especially this particular type of
composting one week after we began
composting our fist donor body the
temperature inside that mound of
woodchips reached a hundred and
fifty-eight degrees Fahrenheit imagine
harnessing that heat to create energy or
comfort the grieving on a cold day the
death care revolution has begun it's an
exciting time to be alive thank you